what one thing well before I don't one
thing we have in common as you waited
tables right yes so me too
okay yeah I feel like we have a lot of
similarities and were you a good
waitress do you think I was a great
waitress yeah girl 100% and and I know
that you like you enjoy your wine I
really do Amy yeah really do you have
like a thing like a whole thing you used
to do with water I'm still kind of proud
of the fact and I mean of course I'm
gonna screw it up now because I'm doing
it on TV but I'm kind of proud of the
fact that I can open a bottle of wine
and tell you about the specials and
distract you from the fact that I'm not
doing a great job
[Laughter]
because you know couple of times when
you've written opening wine and then the
cut of the cork like you get half you're
like and you're like just one second I
just have to check something in the
kitchen
[Applause]
luckily you worked at nice places I were
a comedy club there was no is whiskey
and yes but you know what I happen to I
mean it's weird
interesting
I think we've hidden some stuff to help
you out
what do we have under Jamie let's
celebrate
[Applause]
okay why say we celebrate smart girls
let's do it let's I never had to do this
as a waitress I would have vomited I've
never never had to do that no I'm
seriously it was not fancy at all nobody
ordered a Bud Light Amy and you'd never
show here this looks like somebody's
good wine okay okay all right so I'm
just a couple of specials we have today
and so you have any pasta we do we have
a delicious milky and free I met make it
good in three we can make it go big or
we can tell you it's gluten-free and
you'll never know exactly let's see we
have a branzino tonight that's amazing
observed fully fo not cooked
don't you love fishing we have what else
do we have to say we have a roasted
sirloin with like possibly some risotto
yeah we've risotto I scream which is we
yeah
like and then like also I'm trying to
help you
[Applause]
like a poncho so interesting about bread
[Applause]
you know if you think about bread is it
really fills you up to where you don't
have to eat the meal you're just like
Jesus bread and wine
so I'd okay let me guess your birthday
okay you must be a talk okay
I don't I don't make friends drink alone
so I definitely she's gonna make me go
night-night okay I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this